congressman thanks so much for coming on
that was one of the most amazing
exchanges i think i've ever seen you're
in your own home and sheila jackson lee
tells you to put down the gun what is
this really about
well and she also in that bill they tell
you how to store it you know joe biden
just talked about you have to have a
trigger lock so when the person is
breaking into your home make sure you
have your key next to you to get your
trigger lock off your gun and respond
appropriately i was trying to highlight
to the american people that this isn't
just a magazine ban on rifles this is
every single semi-automatic weapon that
takes more than a 10-round magazine
would be banned three of which i just
happen to have and i showed to make it
very clear that a 10 round magazine
doesn't fit in it so by having the
magazine ban you are effectively banning
all of these handguns that millions
hundreds of millions of americans use
every single day to defend themselves
them families to protect their
homesteads
want to make it really simple why
wouldn't congress require that the laws
it passes restricting and banning
handguns apply to their own bodyguards
if they're sincere if high-capacity
magazines are dangerous then why should
sheila jackson lee's federally funded
bodyguards get to carry them i'm
confused
well and corey bush is on that committee
and she spends hundreds of thousands of
dollars of her campaign money every
single year for bodyguards and security
and i can guarantee you they are using
the exact same weapons that mr jones you
just highlighted talked about banning as
a quote assault rifle or assault weapon
but i mean but why shouldn't the laws
apply to the people who make the laws
that seems like absolutely fairly solid
principle
yeah they absolutely should and that's
that's the hypocrisy of the left joe
biden has all the security nancy pelosi
has all the security the the capitol
police have all the security yet they
want everyday americans like you and me
at our homes at our businesses as we
drive some of us that have concealed
carry permits to not be able to use the
very weapons that we can utilize to
protect our homes our families and our
loved ones and that's exactly what this
is all about
yeah it's time to say no and thank you
for doing that i appreciate it
congressman greg stubey of florida west
coast thanks for having me good to see
you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight